Narrator: Tonight, it's getting
even scarier in the tank.
[ Chainsaw revs ]
Greiner: Oh, God.
[ Screeches ]
You've overvalued
your business.
That's the horror story
you've brought here.
Narrator: And the biggest deal
in "Shark Tank" history is made.
Stop the madness!
Tell us why
you're worth $20 million.
Narrator: In the tank,
hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes of getting
an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Now, what are
we gonna do?
Fiber Fix it!
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
We're not crazy
about the deal, quite honestly.
Why are you
such a greedy pig?
If the sharks
hear a great idea...
Hyah!
Whoa!
...they're ready to invest
using their own money.
And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'm going to
offer you $250,000.
That's ridiculous.
You really need
the right partner to be with.
Thanks, Lori.
Stop singing my praises.
Eric -- Eric --
I'll give you
$2 million for 40%.
Wow!
Narrator:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Daymond John is a fashion
and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first Internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban -- notorious
billionaire entrepreneur,
tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
are entrepreneurs from Utah
who are hoping their product
will become an everyday
household fix-it tool.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Eric Child.
And I'm Spencer Quinn.
And we are Fiber Fix.
Fiber Fix?
Fiber Fix!
[ Laughter ]
We're looking for $90,000
for 10% of our company.
Fiber Fix is the world's
strongest repair wrap.
In fact, it is 100 times
stronger than duct tape.
To show you
just how strong it is,
we created this beautiful hammer
made of 2x2s
wrapped together
with Fiber Fix.
This awesome hammer
is so strong...
Ahh.
...that it can break through
cinder block.
Herjavec:
I don't believe it!
[ Laughs ]
You're gonna believe it.
Hyah!
Ooh.
Whoa!
Stop the madness!
And it gets better.
Fiber Fix saves you
time and money,
and now you can fix things
that you could not fix before.
And you can fix things
with less money.
Leaky pipe?
Fiber Fix it!
Broken tool handles?
Fiber Fix it.
Cracked
your hockey stick?
Okay, everyone say it
with me now.
What are we gonna do?
Fiber Fix it!
Child:
Even broken furniture.
This stool
was broken in two places.
Just wrapped it, sanded it,
painted it -- Fiber Fix!
And, now, sharks,
I'd like you
to take a look
at these samples
that we have here
of the product.
Thank you.
There you go, Robert.
Greiner: Thank you.
Kevin.
Child: Sharks, Fiber Fix
is taking off.
So who's ready to...
Fiber Fix it!
[ Laughter ]
Very good.
Herjavec: Spencer, let me
ask you a question.
How many of these
are we selling right now?!
Over $100,000
worth of product.
In what
period of time?
In the last few months.
We actually --
so, it's brand-new.
It's brand-new.
Why is this better
than duct tape?
Well, why don't we show you
a little demo?
Here's a tent pole
that's been repaired
with duct tape.
Doesn't quite cut it.
Here's a snapped
tent pole
that's been repaired
with Fiber Fix.
Let me see it.
This is incredible.
Yeah. It's awesome,
right?
Greiner:
Let me feel it.
Incredible.
It's a specialized blend
of resin,
along with
industrial-grade fibers.
Cuban: What's the process
to make it work?
I buy it,
and then what do I do?
Quinn: You just take it
out of the pouch.
You dip it in water,
and that activates
the resin that's in the tape.
So it's
water-activated.
You wrap it around
the broken item,
and after
about five minutes,
it's gonna start
to harden.
You have to put it
in water, and you have to --
you -- you can't touch it
with your bare hands?
Child: Well, you're not
gonna want to
because it's -- it's --
it's really sticky,
and once you
get that on your hands,
it's gonna be there
for awhile.
Now, that's
sticky right now.
So, what do you
charge me for this?
So, we sell it
in three different sizes.
Um, the, uh, four-inch
costs $9.99,
the two-inch
costs $7.99,
and the one-inch
costs $5.99.
So, what's your cost?
The average cost
is under $2, landed.
Yours. And what do you
wholesale it for?
For $4.
Greiner: So, where are you
selling right now?
We're in over 400 independent
retailers right now,
but we are now set up
as a vendor with home depot,
and we have a P.O. Coming
for a 240-store test.
O'Leary: You know,
I'll make you an offer.
Very simply -- I give you
the $90,000, I take no equity.
You keep your company.
You pay me back,
every time you sell a unit,
70 cents, until I get
the $90,000 back.
I don't know
how long it's gonna take.
And then after
I get the $90,000 back,
you pay me 20 cents
in perpetuity.
And then you take
your children,
and they have to work
for him forever.
[ Laughs ]
All right, Eric,
I would be your biggest customer
in a single race weekend
on my racecar
using this tape stuff.
[ Laughs ]
Um, I'll give you
the $90,000 for 10%.
Straight in, no royalty,
and we're in this together.
O'Leary: Giving up equity
right at the beginning
can be very expensive
later on.
Eric,
one of my best friends
runs a $16-billion
home hardware company.
Really?
Yeah.
I go over to his house,
there is duct tape everywhere.
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: What if you want to
get it off of something?
How does it remove?
It's tough.
I'm gonna be honest.
It's not coming off.
Eric, why are we
having this discussion?
Let's go sell
some Fiber Fix!
[ Laughter ]
You've got
two offers here.
There's
still questions.
Are there
any other offers here?
Child: We want to hear
from the rest of the sharks,
but before we do,
we want to just alert you
to one other development
in the business.
Um, we recently have received
a purchase order from QVC.
Ah.
You mean there's someone else
on QVC that sells product?
I'm shocked!
It's an opening
test order.
John: Are you definitely
going on to QVC with this?
We're definitely
going on.
We're going on.
If you're already committed
to QVC, I'm out.
I have a deal with HSN.
Okay. We understand.
Thanks, Daymond.
Greiner: I will tell you
what I think here.
That QVC disease
has affected this product.
[ Laughs ]
That QVC will probably
make them very wealthy.
Here's my offer.
I'm going to offer you
$250,000 for 18%,
and I'll tell you why.
One, I know
the power of QVC,
but I also know the power
of QVC when you're with me.
But I think another
huge opportunity here
is the infomercial-spot
market.
Right.
I'll tell you honestly,
you really need
the right partner.
You need somebody
who knows the ropes
and who also knows who are
the good partners to be with.
Thanks, Lori.
Stop singing my praises.
Eric --
Eric, who is --
they know
nothing about it.
Eric, who is the biggest buyer
for this product?
Is it men or women?
We believe
it's probably men.
O'Leary:
I don't think a lot of women
are gonna be
applying this.
I think it's both.
Herjavec:
So, where do you think -- where
do you think most guys shop?
Do you think they shop
online and infomercials,
or do you think
they shop
in a hardware store
with this other stuff?
He's wrong.
Well, there's a lot
of women on --
no, you know, I can immediately
tell you he's wrong.
Any -- any shark --
but all --
any shark can get you
into the infomercial business.
It takes --
that's not true at all.
It is true.
It's -- it is true.
That is true.
Greiner: You know he has
no experience about it.
They can get you in.
I actually
produce these things.
But they can get you in
with the wrong partners.
We're concerned about,
you know,
if it goes well,
now you've got
to put $1 million, $2 million,
$3 million --
Greiner: That's -- that's
exactly the point.
Yeah, but the media-buyer --
media-buyer partners
will -- will do that.
How are you guys gonna pay
for the infomercials?
$90,000
isn't gonna do it.
$120,000
As usual, all roads
lead back to me
because I don't require
any equity in my deal.
I actually don't think
this product
is a, uh -- is the same
as costume jewelry or sponges.
Lori, she made you an offer
of $250,000 for 18%.
That's a lot of equity
to give up early on, of course.
My deal's
so simple for you.
And you give up
no equity.
Robert offered you
exactly what you wanted --
$90,000 for 10%.
Herjavec: Let me
tell you why, Kevin.
$16-billion hardware
retailer with 1,000 locations --
this is the path to go.
There's nothing wrong
with the infomercial,
but I'm telling you
that is not the path
of least resistance to start.
That's
a supplement market.
What's missing
in my offer?
Well, you know
that you need
a strategic partner
that can you take you farther.
Is it
infomercial?
Herjavec: Eric, let me just add
a condition to my offer.
Okay.
I think what you really need
is you need some of the money
to do some development
and other stuff,
but you also need some money
for inventory.
I'll give you the $90,000
for the 10%
and I'll extend you
a $250,000 line of credit
as you need it.
But any of us
can do that, too.
Robert, it sounds
like you've got
some great retail connections
that we could definitely use.
And, Lori, it sounds
like you've got
some great connections
that we could definitely use
in the TV realm.
Can we take a minute?
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
[ Clears throat ]
I don't see equity being
worth anything in this
company. It's a product.
Cuban: Yeah, well,
they underpriced it.
They underpriced it.
It's worth a lot more.
They underpriced it, and they
know they underpriced it.
So, Robert offered 10%.
Exactly
what we want.
Just what we wanted.
$90,000.
$250,000
in a line of credit.
$250,000 -- I don't think
that's enough line of credit.
John:
I'm just curious, Lori,
do you really think
that women are going to want
to put on the gloves
and do all of the --
Daymond, you know
a lot of products like this
sell very successfully
on QVC.
The women buy it
for their husband.
Here we go.
Thanks
for your patience.
Uh, we feel like we need
a big line of credit
as part of the deal.
So, Lori, what we'd like
to offer
is $120,000
for 12% in the company,
plus a $2-million
line of credit.
O'Leary: Oh.
Guys, come on.
I mean, seriously.
Guys, you're --
now you're blowing it.
Narrator: One shark is out,
but with interest
from three sharks,
Spencer and Eric
have changed their offer.
Child: Lori, what we'd like
to offer
is $120,000
for 12% in the company,
plus a $2-million
line of credit.
Guys, come on.
I mean, seriously.
Guys, you're --
now you're blowing it.
Whoa. So, wow.
You guys undervalued
your company
and you realized it,
right?
Sure.
Cuban: That's part of the
game strategy of "Shark Tank."
You have to come in
and try to determine
what valuation
is going to get interest,
but not underprice, because
if you need additional equity,
you've given away
too much.
I think you made
a strategic mistake,
and for
those reasons, I'm out.
Herjavec: Well!
That's interesting.
Put on the gloves.
So, Eric, what are you saying
to my offer and Kevin's offer?
So, with your offer,
Robert --
you're countering
to all three sharks?
We also need the $2-million
line of credit from you.
And what are you saying
to Kevin?
Kevin.
Pound of salt.
We didn't -- we didn't actually
consider that deal much.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah! I like these guys.
We feel like that would
be counterproductive to
the business.
A lot of the cash would be
going out the back door.
Well, if you actually
thought it through,
if you did $100 million
in sales,
my deal would be
much better for you,
'cause your equity
would actually be
significantly more valuable
than the 20-cent royalty
in perpetuity.
That was a mistake
on your part.
See, I'm
a financial advisor.
I understand money.
Sounds like you don't.
[ Chuckles ]
But we do understand
growing a start-up,
and we really need that cash
to grow this business fast.
Herjavec: Eric.
Are we still
talking to Kevin?
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: I'll do the $120,000
for the 12%.
That's it.
I'm not gonna give you
the $2-million line of credit.
If we're doing well,
I'll definitely put up the money
to help fund any orders
that we have
until the money
is rolling in enough
where you can put
the money back into it.
Cuban:
But there's a huge difference
between a line of credit,
which allows you to borrow
to use for any business purpose,
and funding purchase orders.
But your concern is funding
purchase orders, correct?
Yeah, of course.
Eric, is the infomercial route
the way you want to go?
We just feel like
that's a very important
component of this product.
Because it's brand-new,
we need to educate consumers.
So let me -- let me
clear it up then.
You got to get
into retail first.
Well, we definitely want to
do that, as well.
There's no point
in advertising
unless the product's
out there.
Right.
I'm out.
Well, now that Robert's out,
I'm the only game in town.
Yeah, we're not crazy
about the deal, quite honestly.
And I really think
that the line of credit
is important
to the business.
Wow!
Greiner: Why --
why did you need
the $2-million credit
if it's not
to fund purchase orders?
'Cause it's extremely expensive
to get on TV.
Did you guys come in
genuinely wanting
to close a deal?
Sure. We did. Yeah.
Because you do know
what I can offer,
and basically I'm giving you
what you asked for...
Herjavec: Eric, you -- no.
...except I'm not saying,
"here's just a $2-million
line of credit
for whatever
you want to do with it."
Sure.
I'm saying that I would
fund purchase orders.
Guys, now you're
getting greedy.
So, Lori, $120,000 for 12%,
finance all purchase orders.
I said --
I already said that.
Right?
Yep.
That's a partnership.
We need a decision.
Lori...
You have a deal.
Good.
Thank God.
John: Thank goodness.
O'Leary: Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
It's a great product.
Child:
It is a great product.
[ Sighs ]
Greiner: All right.
Thanks, guys.
Uh-huh. Good luck.
Right on, baby!
I would have
never done that.
I felt like they were the sharks
and you were pitching them.
You know what?
You guys!
It's disgusting
how much you criticize
when I'm the winner
and you're the loser.
Narrator: Last season,
Jeff Stafford and Dusty Holloway
made a deal with Mark Cuban
for their product, Shellbobbers,
fishing bobbers
made from shotgun shells.
Deal? Done.
Yes. We will
accept your offer.
Narrator: Let's see
how they're doing now.
Stafford: Business has been
awesome since "Shark Tank."
It feels like I'm on
a roller coaster
that's going, like,
3,000 miles an hour.
After landing our deal,
we knew we had to scale quickly.
We moved into
a 3,500-square-foot facility,
hired a team of employees,
and brought in the automation
we needed
to pump these things
out quick.
I went from making 100 a day
to 25,000 every day.
Cool. Cool.
Got it.
All right?
Thanks, man.
It feels really good
being able to keep shellbobbers
made in America.
To be able to provide jobs
in our hometown
has just been
really cool to see.
Perfect. Ready to go.
Stafford: Thank you.
Before "Shark Tank," we had less
than $1,000 in sales.
After making our deal
with mark,
we're in the largest retailer
in the world, 7-Eleven.
Now we're projecting
over $1 million in sales
over the next
12 months.
It's two pallets.
Two pallets, yeah.
I can have that out
by Thursday.
The experience has been a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity,
and it's all thanks
to "Shark Tank."
All: Thank you, "Shark Tank"!
Whoo!
I'm Amanda Adams.
I'm Jason Adams.
And we're
from Mckinney, Texas.
Amanda and I met a year ago
on a blind date.
We fell in love and got married
within six weeks.
We both had kids,
so we blended
our families together,
and now we're expecting
a baby boy.
Combining two
already-established families
is difficult
and takes a lot of work.
You've got to find
a good way to communicate.
But if we put that
like that?
That could work.
We developed
a product
to save marriages
and relationships.
It was born out of love
to help couples like us
communicate our thoughts
and feelings,
even when it's tough.
We know people.
We know relationships.
Manufacturing,
price points, and margins
are not
our strong points.
This is where the sharks
can really help us.
We need to make
this deal.
We've invested over $100,000
to make our dream a reality.
And we feel
very passionate
that this can help save
millions of relationships.
Hello, sharks.
I'm Jason.
I'm Amanda.
This is baby Koa.
And we are
the Adams family.
Our company
is Elephant Chat,
and we're seeking
a $50,000 investment
for a 20% stake
in our company.
No one likes those "we need
to talk" conversations.
But they are
necessary.
And most of the time,
you don't know that you
need to have that talk
until you start getting
the cold shoulder
and end up
sleeping on the couch.
Until now.
We designed a product
that allows you
to visually tell
your partner
you have something
to talk about.
Introducing
the elephant in the room.
John: Oh, lord.
[ Laughter ]
Is that
a stuffed animal?
It is
a stuffed elephant.
So, when I see the toilet seat
has been left up
for the millionth time,
I don't have to be ready
to pounce on him
when he walks
through the door
or be mad when he doesn't
realize I'm upset.
I simply remove
the cover
and reveal the elephant
in the room.
So, when I get home and I see
the elephant is in the room,
I immediately know
that she has something
she wants
to talk about,
which allows me
to understand her mood,
but gives me time
to settle in.
Then when I'm ready,
I simply say,
"you want to talk about
the elephant in the room?"
And one of the best rules
about Elephant Chat
is that you can only talk
if you're holding the elephant.
So, which one
of you sharks
would like to be the first
to talk about
the elephant
in the room?
Oh. Lord.
Amanda,
how long you been married?
Um, well, actually, today
is our 13th-month anniversary.
Is one of you
a therapist?
We are not.
What we landed on
was this worked for us.
John: If you're
really married --
and they
obviously are.
Yeah, you know
the rules.
There's
one person right
and the other person's
the husband.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
That's it.
Th-there's -- there's --
there's nothing to discuss.
[ Laughter ]
So, how much
does each one cost to make?
To make -- on our very first run
of 500, it was $22.
Whoa!
Oh, my goodness.
Whoa! Each?
Whoa!
Greiner: You know,
can I see the box, 'cause I --
O'Leary: You have to sell the --
the elephant for 150 bucks!
Jason, what do you sell
the elephant for?
$59 is what
we're looking at.
[ Laughs ]
How much money did you put
to start the business?
Okay.
We -- we raised $100,000.
Raised?
We have seven -- we just --
our local friends.
[ Laughter ]
They won't be friends
for long.
Greiner:
You guys, the thing is,
like, a stuffed elephant animal
is very inexpensive to make.
That's correct.
It costs you
a lot of money
to go into that box
with tooling,
so, to make the decision
and spend that much money
when you're a brand-new business
is a wonderment to me,
because that's a risk
and it's a big expense.
You know what?
The -- the finances actually
worked out the best for us,
'cause, as we started
to look
at all the other boxes
that existed out there,
there wasn't another way
to get a clear plastic
inside of a covered plastic.
But, Jason, just staying
on theme here for a second...
Yes.
...I go online,
I click on stuffed elephants.
Here's one for $2.99.
Here's one for $69.
That's right.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: $59.
I get exactly
what you're saying.
The -- the issue here,
is that says,
every single person
has -- has something
that they really
want to say.
Can I have the elephant?
Yes.
Thank you.
When you
first start out,
one -- you do it
as inexpensively
as you possibly can,
because you don't know
if this will succeed.
Two -- I think
it's very important
to offer something
at a very affordable price.
It wasn't
gonna work for me,
for her
to take it serious
that I wanted to build
better communications
if it was $19.99
for two of them
and I got a free snuggie
with it.
But, you guys,
at $60 apiece,
I don't think
it would ever sell.
I'm out.
Well, thank you.
Thank you, Lori.
So, our first strategy
is that we've
made relationships and inroads
with the marriage
counseling
and other counseling
industries, so --
[ laughs ]
You're kidding.
O'Leary: You got to be
kidding.
I would buy that box
for $60,
open it up, and find
a $1 stuffed elephant in it.
If your phone number
was in there...
[ Laughter ]
...you can sell me
some tickets
to an anger-management show,
because I would be very unhappy.
The consumer experience
of getting completely
ripped off blind
is going to be
an unpleasant one.
Well --
and -- and for
that reason, Jason,
um, I'm definitely out.
Okay.
My wife gets really mad
at me sometimes.
I don't know why,
'cause I'm the perfect husband.
Right.
I'm just picturing
going to her
with a little stuffed animal
and saying,
"honey,
don't yell at me."
I don't know
if that's gonna work.
Well -- well,
from the marriage counselors
that we've talked to,
they love the idea,
because right now,
they use this method,
but they use it with pencils
and random objects.
Amanda, you've been married
for 13 months.
Come talk to me
after 23 years.
Right.
Okay?
I'm out.
Daymond.
We still have
$53,000 in cash.
We own
three injection molds,
and we have
the first 500 units.
Um, if I came home,
this would be
an early warning signal.
I would
slide out the window
and hop the back gate
and go to a bar
and not come home
until the next day...
Exactly.
...because this would mean that,
"honey, we have to talk."
Maybe that's why
you're not married.
Maybe.
This just isn't for me.
I'm out.
We appreciate it.
Thank you.
I --
I think mark may --
mark may be in on this one.
Cuban: First -- first, I think
these guys are all wrong.
Okay? I think the product
should be more expensive.
You guys are in the
conflict-resolution business.
Jason:
That's right.
Now, trying to sell this
in a retail environment --
isn't gonna work.
Forget it, right?
And that -- that wasn't
our focus.
You go to
the marriage counselors
with the 500 units
that you have,
and this is
a conflict-resolution device --
there's nobody who needs
corny stuff
more than
marriage counselors.
Right.
Mark, what are
you gonna do?
I can't go in 'cause you guys
aren't where you need to be yet.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you very much
for your time.
O'Leary: All right, guys.
Congratulations.
Good luck.
John: Congratulations.
Thank you. Congratulations.
Good luck with the baby.
Thank you.
We know this works.
We know how it worked
for us and our marriage.
And everyone
we talk to loves it.
And, so, we're gonna
continue to go forward.
Yeah.
Love you.
[ Snarling ]
Narrator: Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur
who believes there's big money
to be made from big scares.
Oh.
[ Laughs ]
[ Chuckles ]
Everywhere I go,
there's zombies.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Melissa Carbone
from Los Angeles,
and my company
is Ten Thirty One Productions,
and I'm seeking $2 million
in exchange
for 10% of my company.
Oh.
Wow.
Ten Thirty One Productions
is an entertainment company
that creates, owns,
and produces
live attractions
in the horror space.
Our most popular attraction
is the Los Angeles
Haunted Hayride.
And it is
not for the faint of heart.
Sharks,
when you take our hayride,
you are entering
the pitch black woods.
Where demonic forces,
lost souls,
psychopathic fun
are waiting around every turn.
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: Oh, God.
Cuban:
Let's hope he bites.
[ Screeches ]
And just when you think
the terror is over,
think again.
Oh, God.
[ Laughs ]
[ Hisses ]
[ Chainsaw revs ]
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: Oh, my God!
Cuban: He likes you.
Don't eyeball me.
I will kick your tush
back to Texas.
Greiner: Get him, mark!
Get him!
O'Leary: Okay, Melissa,
you know what's really
scaring the crap out of me
is your valuation.
So, $2 million
for 10%
imputes a $20-million value
on this scary-hayride business.
Tell us why
you're worth $20 million.
We do attractions
all year long.
We have the Los Angeles
Haunted Hayride,
which is our seasonal attraction
here in L.A.
17 nights -- we sell out
every single night.
We do about $1.8 million
right now per October.
Herjavec: Whoa!
Cuban: Really? Oh, wow.
$1.8 million
is really good.
In 17 days.
It's fantastic
in 17 days.
In 17 days.
Carbone:
We have another attraction
called The Great Horror Campout
that we just launched,
which is a summer attraction.
The Great Horror Campout
is our way of not being
a seasonal company.
It is an overnight, completely
immersive camping experience --
horror themed.
Oh, no.
So, it's 12 hours.
We ba-- we take 2,000 campers,
we put them in tents,
and we have an incredibly
interactive experience.
Cuban: Oh.
That sounds amazing.
Wow.
Carbone: That includes
everything from a hell hunt --
so, it's basically
summer camp from hell.
Yeah.
$1.8 million in at the end
of the 17 days. What's left?
It costs us $1.2 million
to produce the Los Angeles
Haunted Hayride.
So, I'm left with $600,000
free cash afterwards?
Yeah, I mean,
it varies year to year
because right now we're in a
launching-new-attraction mode.
We're launching a New York
Haunted Hayride,
which is what we're seeking
some of this money for.
The Great Horror Campout,
we're launching it next year
in 10 cities up the west coast.
Cuban: And therein lies
the rub, right?
Because they're very, very, very
expensive to produce and create.
Right, well, the -- the campouts
are cheap to produce.
Cuban: How much advertising
and promotion do you do?
We spend about $300,000.
We do a ton of radio.
My background is
I-I ran Clear Channel
Los Angeles for 10 years,
so my advertising, marketing,
and one of --
wow.
And my other business partner
is actually
still with Clear Channel.
So we know how to make
a dollar go really far
from a marketing standpoint.
How many unique individuals
come through?
The hayride?
Yeah.
We have --
we have 50,000 people.
We sell out
every single night.
So, this year
is our first year
we increased our max capacity
to 100,800.
We actually are doubling
our max capacity this year
'cause we've --
you -- you sell out
every night for 17 days?
Every night.
Herjavec:
That's amazing.
So, can I extrapolate
and say
that it's gonna be $3.6 million
in revenue this year?
Yes, if we sell out.
So, that means
this thing will generate
just over a million bucks
if everything works, right?
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Now, you're
an intelligent woman.
I'm trying
to make the leap now.
We have to get back to reality
and your $20-million ask.
Yeah.
Let's give you
a fair chance
of making a million bucks
before tax, okay?
Yeah. Yep.
That's about
$700,000 after tax.
If I gave you
a 10 multiple,
you're worth
7 million bucks.
How is it that I am going
to pay $20 million
for a $7-million
business?
If everything
goes right.
That's the horror story
you've brought here.
You've overvalued
your business.
We've had major entertainment
companies in L.A.
who have already given us
offers to buy our company,
and this is about
what they're valuing it.
Why are you
such a greedy pig?
Greiner: I --
[ laughs ] Kevin!
I'm not greedy.
I have lots of -- lots of
high hopes for the company.
And I want to grow fast.
Well -- well, let me ask
you something. Where --
where did this --
you're beating
a dead horse.
Just because
a Hollywood bozo
offered you
a $20-million valuation --
Cuban: You know what
the horror show is?
Listening to you argue
about valuation all the time.
Well, then, why don't you just
give her $2 million for 10%?
Carbone: I am projecting for
the New York Haunted Hayride,
which hasn't happened yet --
'cause it's the same
model in L.A., we're
just plopping it there.
O'Leary: But you
haven't done it yet.
John: But hold on.
Cuban: Let her go,
let her go, let her go.
Go ahead.
But geographically
it's a different model
because it never rains
in L.A.
Listen, I-I-I-I don't agree
that your risk analysis
is correct.
It never happens
that everything you roll out
is successful day one.
That's ridiculous.
Carbone:
For me, it is not hard
to get lots of people
to come to the attractions.
The hard part is to make it
a great experience
so they want to come back.
Look, this is
all fun and games,
but we're talking
about money here.
I can't --
I can't get there.
I'm out.
Herjavec: Melissa, for you
to come close
to your projections
for next year,
everything has to work
perfectly all the time.
I don't see you getting
to those numbers next year.
I'm out.
For me right now
to give you $2 million,
I feel it would take
a really long time
for me to see
that back.
So, for that reason,
I'm out.
[ Growling ]
Carbone:
The risk is not as great
as you probably would think.
I mean, we will launch these
attractions no matter what.
I know that we can
launch them faster.
By having this money,
we can launch them now.
I'm an expert
in high-octane scare.
You are?
Yes, I can tell you a way
to do this much cheaper.
Wear a piece of jewelry
and walk around
where I grew up.
[ Laughter ]
That will give you
a high-octane scare.
Fair enough.
Uh, I would just have to
insult you with my offer.
Um...
Go ahead. Insult her.
That's about what it's worth.
Throw the offer.
Yeah.
Okay, well, then, I'll give you
$2 million for 40%.
Cuban: [ Scoffs ]
Okay.
Mark?
Come on, Mark.
Is that a yes
or a no to him?
Um...
Can I counter?
Of course
you can counter.
Um, $2 million for 20%.
I'll take that offer.
Done.
Really?
Yep.
Greiner: Awesome!
Go, Mark!
So, we have a deal?
John: Take it.
All right.
We have a deal.
Whoo-hoo!
Wow!
Easy, breezy.
I love it.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm so excited.
Thanks.
Don't
think about it.
Herjavec: Wow, Daymond.
Buttered her up for Mark.
Holy cow!
You owe me 5%
for helping you on that.
Totally.
You can have free tickets
to the L.A. Haunted Hayride.
Thank you so much,
you guys.
Cuban: Thanks, Melissa.
Appreciate it.
Greiner: Good luck.
John: I don't know what just
happened. Wait a minute.
I lost out on a deal,
come to think of it.
Yeah, you just did.
[ Snarls ]
I think that the
next generation of entertainment
is experiential
entertainment,
where people get out
of the house
and go and get
a unique experience.
I thought for me
to get my money back
if I did that deal
for $2 mil,
I'd have to rise from the dead
and look like that
before I get anything.
You already have,
Kevin.
Are we excited?
[ Screeching ]
With mark on board
and $2 million,
this is
the biggest deal ever.
I'm so excited.
This changes
the game for us.
[ Chainsaw revs ]
Wow!
Narrator: Next into the tank
are self-described mini sharks
from New Jersey with a unique
opportunity for the sharks.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Jason Reddish.
And my name
is Val Pinkhasov.
Our company
is total merchant resources.
We're seeking $200,000
in exchange for 20%
of our company.
One of the most frequent causes
of a failed business
is being
undercapitalized.
That's where total merchant
resources comes in,
because we're mini sharks.
It's like
looking in the mirror.
Every entrepreneur that walks
through these doors needs money.
But with this
financial meltdown,
it's been
virtually impossible
for businesses
to get their hands on money.
Just like
we're coming to you
for an investment
and a partnership,
we have responsible
business owners
coming to us daily
for similar reasons.
That's right.
Total merchant resources
provides alternative
financing solutions
so they can get the capital
they need quickly
to give their business
a shot in the arm.
So, with your help,
we want to expand our reach,
fund more
small businesses...
Both: And swim
with the big sharks.
Let's do it.
[ Laughter ]
You guys do get
the irony here, right?
Greiner:
Yeah, right?
Yeah,
you're competing.
Let's talk about
a typical loan.
Let's say
I own a dog-grooming --
well, first -- first,
is it loans --
is it loans or are --
'cause you said "underwriting."
That's
a great question.
It's loans.
It's not really a loan.
Semantically,
I mean, you could take --
you're taking equity.
We're not taking equity.
Well, let's say
you're a restaurant --
take an example.
I'm a dog groomer.
My sales are
$80,000 a year,
and I need another $20,000
so I can do more.
All right?
I can't get that from a bank.
I'm too small.
I come to tmr --
total merchant resources.
Both: That's right.
And I say
I need $20,000.
What are the terms under which
I get that $20,000?
If they qualify,
we'll give them $20,000.
What are the terms?
They will pay us back
on the $20,000
approximately $26,000
to $28,000,
depending on the risk
of their business.
What are the terms?
What's the annualized
interest rate?
What percentage?
Well, the --
there is no term.
What we do is we collect
a specific amount
of their credit-card sales
until we get paid back,
which is why there's no --
you're Kevin!
Which is why --
almost like a royalty.
Which is why
there's no term.
Because we're taking over
their credit-card processing.
Let's say the merchant
batches $1,000 tonight.
$800 is gonna hit
that merchant's account,
and $200 is gonna hit
our account
till we're paid back.
Now --
Cuban: I got it, I got it,
I got it. Okay.
So, you use
lending somebody money
as a foot in the door
to get their processing account.
It's ancillary --
it's an ancillary --
right. So, okay.
So, I would have
a restaurant,
and I need $50,000 to upgrade,
improve the restaurant,
whatever it may be.
And I go to you guys
and say, "yo, Jason."
"Jason, what's up?"
"I need a little bit
of cash here.
You know, these banks,
they ain't giving me nothing."
Is my accent that bad?
"Yeah, nothing, right?
They ain't givin' me nothing."
I've taken
speech classes.
[ Laughs ]
"You say,
$50,000, mark."
"Fitty"? "Fitty"?
"Fitty" thousand.
"Mark, I got you.
"You're doing
a million in revenue.
Where -- you just switch your
credit-card processing to us."
Wink, wink.
"We're gonna take 6% off your
sales or whatever it may be,
"and when you're paid off,
you're paid off,
"and, oh, by the way,
we do credit-card processing
better than anybody," right?
Cuban: Am I right on that?
We take over 74% --
John: Is he right?
74% of the business
that we have coming in,
we take over
the processing.
Does Val end up
at their door...
With a baseball bat?
...in the middle
of the night?
[ Laughter ]
Jason, Val,
what's your background?
Are you finance guys?
I owned a-a decent-size
mortgage company
for about 10 years.
And what's
your background?
And I was in mortgage sales
for awhile.
I ran offices.
About six years ago,
I actually interviewed
at Jason's office
for a management position,
and I was hired.
What are your sales?
In 2012, we did $364,000
in gross sales, okay?
Our take-home on that
was about $220,000
in distributions.
So, what we need
from you sharks, okay,
is to be able
to introduce us
to the bigger credit-card
processing accounts,
because that's the only
component of this business
that requires
the who-you-know factor.
Herjavec: But where are you
gonna get the float?
Where are you
gonna get the extra cash?
Well, I'm -- I'm getting
to that, right?
So, once we get the credit-card
processing accounts
on board
through your connections,
those accounts throw off
a very nice-size residual.
Jason, Kevin's example
of the dog groomer --
if someone's doing $80,000
a year and they need 20 grand,
there's no way
that business could afford
to pay you back
in 12 months.
It could. It could.
So, we already have
a successful track record.
We only started
with $5,000, okay?
That $5,000 has grown over time
to be worth over $100,000.
Greiner: You guys, I'm not
really sure about all of this,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
I -- a tanning salon
in bayside, queens. All right?
Air-conditioning unit
blows on --
hey, I went to
bayside high.
A guy needs $18,000
to fix his hvac
on his roof, right?
How long does it take
a guy running a tanning salon
to get $18,000 together
to fix the thing on the roof?
Herjavec: Never.
Right.
If I'm not there,
he's out of business.
Yeah.
We get him funded
in three or four days.
Herjavec:
All right, Jason, look,
there is an entire subset
of small businesses
that cannot get a loan,
but it -- it's
not a market for me.
This isn't a business
that I would want to be in.
I'm out.
Even though
there's a 400% return
in less than a year,
two years?
That's a pretty --
I mean, it's -- we have
a successful track record.
Cuban: But, guys,
that's part of the problem.
That -- that -- that's
the upside and the downside.
The risk
is government, right?
Right now,
there aren't limitations,
but it's almost
like payday loans,
until they got so popular
people started to complain,
and then
the government stepped in
and started to introduce
regulations.
We have testimonials --
no joke --
where clients were actually
crying on the phone
saying,
"val, I'm so happy
that you were able
to get this to me,"
because we want to be able
to come through for them.
Look, I get it.
There's a value.
I'd actually rather see them
go through you
than take a loan
from the bank,
because at least you guys
will care and work with them,
but it still makes me
feel uncomfortable.
You know, they always say
that when something goes wrong,
they go to
the deepest pockets.
And I'd be
your deepest pockets.
For that reason,
I'm out.
Daymond?
O'Leary: I happen to think
that what you do
is a necessary --
and some of these sharks
think -- it's a necessary evil.
It's still necessary
to keep a business afloat.
That's all that matters.
I'm gonna make
the assumption
that you were smart enough
to get in front of me
in "Shark Tank," that I should
be your partner.
But that will not happen
unless I have 50%.
Ba-bam.
Narrator: Four sharks are out.
Kevin is Jason and Val's
last chance for a deal.
O'Leary: I'm gonna make
the assumption
that you were smart enough
to get in front of me
in "Shark Tank," that I should
be your partner.
But that will not happen
unless I have 50%.
Ba-bam.
I'll give you $200,000
to be 50% partner
in this business.
And I'll probably take you
to a whole new level.
There's no question
about it.
I have access to capital
you only dream of.
You know what it is?
You know, it's funny, val.
We were joking with you
about strong-arm tactics,
and then you met
Mr. O'Leary
with the $200,000
for 50% offer.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
I just happen to think
I bring a tremendous amount
of credibility to this business
and capital and contacts,
and for me to ask
to be a 50/50 partner
is not unreasonable
in my view.
And so your dis-- distribution
just got cut in half.
Yeah, so, what you're
asking us to do
is basically take three years
of our life
and cut it
in a quarter.
I just put capital
in for $200,000.
You can't tell me right now
you're worth --
well, can I --
can I explain -- hold on.
The capital --
hold on. Can I explain how
we -- we got to the valuation?
No, they didn't ask --
instead of starting it
myself,
I'm giving up from day one
half the equity to you two guys.
That's the way
I look at it,
because if I want
to do this, I can.
I can do it myself, okay?
Cuban: See, in Kevin's defense,
the minute you guys walk out,
he takes out some ads, goes --
goes to a headhunting firm,
and says, "you know what?
Find me the best.
"And I'll pay them --
you know,
if it was that easy --
Cuban: And I'll pay them
$500,000 a year."
You got the best
in front of you.
Val, who cares?
What are you gonna do?
$200,000, 50%.
What do you think
the probability is
that people
return my phone call?
Very high.
Thank you.
Go think about it.
Whew.
Oh, boy.
You know,
they brought up a good point.
How many businesses
on "Shark Tank"
could use
a processing service like this?
A lot.
He's -- he's asking us
to give us --
it's two times earnings,
and that's insane.
Right. Yeah.
You know, you really are
the right partner for it.
I think so, too.
I think they should
take your deal.
You're the only up here
that has that element.
You know, your only question is,
are these the guys
who are gonna take you
to the promised land?
Jason, Val,
welcome back to the tank.
Kevin made you an offer --
$200,000 for 50%.
You know, Kevin,
we feel that our sales,
our revenue, has tremendous
value, as well.
And granted,
those bar-- barriers to entry,
like you mentioned --
guys, I'm paying 10 times what
you put up to start this thing,
and there's no barriers
to entry.
Make a counter.
So we want to do $250,000
for 25% equity.
No. No.
Try to be
more reasonable than 50%.
If I put my name
on a business,
it's going to geometrically
increase the a.U.M. --
the assets under management.
If you don't believe that,
turn around,
walk out the door.
You can walk right out
of the Shark Tank
and you'll stay small.
Nobody
wants to bid for this?
You could always say, "I'm not
out." You've heard more.
John: Guys, guys, you got to
give this guy an answer.
Cuban: Got to
make a call, guys.
We got to stop
thinking about it.
It's binary.
Yes or no.
$200,000 at 40%?
Nope.
There is no flexibility,
my friend.
It's yes or no.
Binary. On or off.
There's
always flexibility.
There isn't.
I-if it was guaranteed
that we would
be blowing up?
Jason, come on.
There are no --
there's no guarantees.
You -- you know
whether or not --
why don't you guys
just flip a coin?
Just get it over with.
Just flip a coin.
Flip a coin?
Yeah,
if it means that --
Reddish:
That's life, usually.
Come on, Jason. You know
what you want to do.
[ Sighs ]
You got to make a decision.
Got a coin?
[ Laughs ]
I'll let you
flip a coin. That's fine.
Kevin, Kevin.
I got a quarter.
Reddish: Hey, is there any way
another shark
would get involved
at that deal?
$200,000, 50%,
100, 100.
My deal is very simple.
You know what it is.
Do you want me
to flip this coin,
or do you want
to say yes now?
I'll say...
I think
we should say yes.
Heads, we're your partner,
tails, we're your partner.
You got a deal.
[ Laughs ]
Aw, I wanted to see
the coin flip.
This is
my favorite coin.
Wow.
Both sides, I win.
Can I have that coin?
Would you mind?
This is
the first distribution.
Congratulations, guys.
Congratulations.
Reddish: Thanks.
Now, this is actually
the one business
where you put up a little money
and you hire somebody,
you could replicate it.
I could have.
But what I like is they've got
an existing book,
and they're probably
good foot soldiers.
My man!
Whoo!
[ Both laugh ]
Rear naked choke
on the counter.
Reddish: The definition
of a good deal
is when two people walk away
a little unhappy.
I think in this case
Mr. Wonderful
might have walked away
a little too happy.
But I guess
only time will tell
once we're on the cover
of Forbes magazine.